about total points under so uh I think I
think we we got the chats A-Okay with
that one
um back in the chat do you see anything
MB I see you looking
yes sir bagel and locks is saying Bruce
Brown under 10 and a half's got to be
free money no
let me take a look at the numbers Bruce
Brown has not had a very great Series so
far and he doesn't play a ton of minutes
so I definitely am not against this play
I don't know if you guys I don't know if
you have a different take Ryan you're
the one that's kind of all over the
bench players these days
you don't start as bench players when I
when I get on their unders uh no I think
uh listen I also like part of this too
and I gave I gave our guy some slack the
last show I was all over the place last
show uh but Bagel unlocks is turning
around uh the man has been on fire and
if he likes Bruce Brown under 10 and a
half points I like it too I you're right
he hasn't been playing well and I think
when you kind of get on the road in
these big games in the playoffs those
role players don't play as well as they
do at home
they're in Miami uh so I'm in I'm taking
Bruce Brown's under 10 and a half
and we could honestly like like we said
we could tease it up obviously once we
figure out what we need but I don't
think it's a bad play he had 11 last
game but 10 and six the game before so
you know you're only playing 20 22
minutes you're gonna have to really
light it up so I don't hate it I'm down
to ride with Mr Bagel
all right as we locking in the under
with Bruce Brown
El Bay is saying he's a nuggets fan but
Bruce gets going he always gets at least
10.
well he can get 10.
if elbe said he always gets at least 11
then that that's a problem for us
good point Ryan good point Hitman Zaza
Hitman Zaza I think we're good with
Bruce Brown we're gonna move it if we
need B but I think we're all aligned
I think so so let's move on I see Hitman
Zaza Kevin Love under one and a half
threes Kevin Love one and a half threes
we don't have to take it I'm just in the
common surfing and this is what hitman's
as I came up with what do you guys think
about it what do you thinking bowling
I think that Kevin Love Actually might
have a pretty decent game tonight I
don't know why I feel like he plays
better at home
you just never know I mean they ran a
damn play for him once and smoked me on
a first basket I don't know if it's one
of those games but
he does get some shots up and he
definitely does float around the arc
instead of hanging out in the paint he's
not going to be a guy who's going to
have his back to the basket often so
he's pretty efficient I probably would
pass here what do you think Ryan
I probably would also pass
um I will say this though I actually
disagree on the Kevin Love thing I think
he had a really good game last game I
just don't know if at this point in his
career he's like he's like that
consistent like if he doesn't come out
and play well I don't what's the
incentive for SPO to keep him out there
like we've seen him for sure have games
where he's just not out there and he
disappears I don't necessarily know if I
want to arrive that inconsistency wave
um I do have a backup though from uh
T-Bone 1581
said bam under on assist I like this
because I saw a stat earlier today that
Bam's over on assists is the most bet
player prop uh of this game
um so I would like to fade the public uh
if we're all okay on that and this is
again not coming from me T-Bone 1581
it's there
thoughts
hey let's do it let's do it I'm with it
I'm with it I'm down
definitely down to fade the public
anytime we get a chance to anytime we
can we can fade the public for show
um
I'm in the comments I'm in the comments
somebody M boo AZ says do these ever hit
in fact
no they don't
know
we just hit one
I was just joking
[Laughter]
that's awesome
they're in the comments saying jokic
under 20 points we're definitely not
rocking with that D Brown I am sorry I'm
actually trying to win this he must be
trolling yo that's crazy totally he
might have 20 in the first time
yeah
yeah it's crazy which yeah which you
know call back for 50 plus
yeah that would be nice arm Beast is
saying Jimmy Butler underpoints he's
been getting assists I don't know if
he's gonna do that well at home if it
makes I don't know if he does that well
at home if it makes a difference if
we're gonna mess with Jimmy Butler's
under
I think I would probably do like under
30. we're already at plus 10. I mean we
can we can move a lot of these numbers I
think if we need to just get to plus 400
so
I might be down with with a big big
under
give us some cushion because who knows
man Jimmy's feel like he's just been
waiting in the weeds to have his big
game I don't know if we want to get
burnt tonight in game three at home yeah
I mean even if he's if he has that big
game I don't will 30 be enough
yeah it's a good point I mean like when
I watched the last game you know they
win by three and they got performances
out of everybody else and they still I
mean I feel like they should have won
that game by 20. so I don't know if you
get 35 from Jimmy
does that mean they lose probably I mean
they they did the same with jokic jokic
have 41 and 11 and they lost so
I don't know it's tough to see yeah I
think that heat maybe we just leave
Jimmy alone
somebody said Jimmy under assists in the
chat
um I think that that person's probably
sharp I don't know if we want to go in
that direction
why is the chat on screen no I can't
even get away with this nonsense anymore
the chat's on screen what are we doing
um
El Bay is dropping a scoop Jimmy hasn't
scored 30 in his last seven games saw
that we ride the train
no I mean
yeah it's like a blackjack table you
gotta go up and there's seven black in a
row I'm probably better soon yeah yeah
I'm right there with you I'm I'm right
there with you
yeah
I hate it when people do that as soon as
he thinks so we think he's not gonna
have a game he's he scores 45 and then
yeah like is Jimmy not gonna ever score
30 points again like oh he has to score
he has a score in this last seven oh
okay
lock he ain't scoring 30. he's never
gonna do it again what do you mean
hey KJ Williams says kcp under points
kcp underpoints
Casey in all honesty kcp is a big factor
in this game
I really think coach Malone called out
kcp
and mpj
after the game with this comments I
think after the game
I think they're both gonna hoop tonight
for sure yeah I mean I don't know like
we saw all the slander about Max oh no
bro and then he had 12 points in the
first quarter like I don't know my thing
is though MB Miami turns up the defense
in South Beach
they have to turn that defense up in
South Ash Jason Tatum I mean they turned
the defense up in South Beach in in in
you know kcp is he is he is he gonna is
he gonna perform under the pressure in
South Beach I don't know
we could have left Jason Tatum out of
this
yeah
and I forgot everything that Greg said
after that
mvuaz saying what about Aaron Gordon's
under
he's only hit over 12 and a half cents
two of his last 10 games so I see Jay
Joseph 56 says Aaron Gordon under 16 and
in the half that's an alternate under
I like it I like it I like that scoring
17 points man he doesn't make enough
threes you I don't think he's getting
eight layups and even then he would
still be under so under 16.5 to me
sounds pretty good yeah I like that
see now we're at plus 651 and we can
start moving these numbers around you
know what I'm saying like we could go
under under
five assists yeah under five assists
maybe move the total up one two maybe
yep
gross Brown a pointer too
nah
I like it bro
if we go under what what is the yeah
that's good too much that's fine yeah no
that's fine yeah that's fine plus 364.
but for him add one more
yeah
I don't know I don't know guys
I would if all right if I was gonna move
anything I would move the the game total
yeah me too I wouldn't have touched uh
yeah I would remove the game total
to okay
let's see what we can get here because I
think that I think this is going to be
pretty low scoring but it is game three
and
the adjustments will happen obviously so
we just gotta this game is in Miami
yeah and I think that's very important
this game is in Miami the the Heat play
different at home they are defensive
juggernauts at home we're gonna see
everybody's talking jokish this yolkest
that nuggets offense this nuggets
offense that
but nobody's really talking about that
heat defense and since
I could remember fellas defense is the
one defense is the thing that wins
championships so amen wait what are you
doing why did you why did you leave
well we can't we we can't uh can't same
game parlay and Alternate total so oh
damn we're cut that's sickening that's
sickening you know what that means guys
we gotta take it out
we gotta take it out oh let's move bam
what about bam almost four and a half
move bam to four and a half or four see
what that's it gives you there we go
four and a half that works I like it yes
sir yes sir
are we locking this in I'm cool with it
I'm cool with this yeah I mean like
Bruce Brown gives me agita but it's
whatever you know
I'm in all right well everybody you know
you guys know what to do take a
screenshot of the parlay it's to the
right of your screen uh but but but but
in between time between time
Ryan
do what you do best can you review the
parlay for the people
yeah man I really thought we were gonna
skip this because it's not on the screen
but now we need you more than ever Ryan
yeah
this is my time to shine yeah dude yeah
there we go Spin Zone all right guys I
got you don't worry Bruce Brown under 10
and a half points Aaron Gordon under 16
and a half points alternate alternate if
you're seeing this and you're saying he
ain't score that's his line that's we
moved we moved it under 200 213 and a
half total points right Greg's got the
scoop the Heat play defense at home uh
not on the road though bam autobio under
four and a half assists that's an
alternate we bumped it up one under four
and a half assists uh that's a fade to
public type of play but those four legs
plus 462
go bet it or fade it or don't bet it I
don't know man just do it or screenshot
it screenshot screenshot screenshots so
I don't have to read it again
make sure you head on over to FanDuel
and uh Ryan when the people head on over
to FanDuel I heard FanDuel got something
very special you want to talk to them
yeah yeah so if your first time
Vandal user uh you get you bet five
dollars you get 150 in bonus pets
guaranteed
think about what you could do with 150
in bonus bets think about it
Superstars you can bet on the Miami Heat
with Greg
don't don't be giving out minus 400
please
sorry dude it's not minus 400 anymore
though it's minus 220 at this point
that's true yeah
Greg
we talk Investments MB I was letting
Ryan do his thing man you know he likes
to he likes to talk a little bit so I
was letting him do his thing and then we
just go we get on
but let's let's get on over to best best
here we this is how we gonna do it
we're gonna have Ryan bat lead off MB
you go second
and then I'mma uh I'm gonna clean this
thing on up hitting third though all
right so Ryan all right take it away
yeah dude you got the Speedster batting
lead off right it's just about getting
on base it's just about getting on base
here
um
yes sir dude
he is on the strike zone man don't get
too aggressive
all right speaking of that though we're
2-0 2-0 so far in fading Superstars the
NBA Finals right in six now we're 12 and
six by that map I'm on a four game
heater here Jimmy Butler assist
six and a half we're going under dude
under hold on let me click on it
under under six and a half assists for
Jimmy Butler uh the last two games nine
assists seven assists the last time he
has had three games of over this total
six and a half was back in November dude
I was buttoned up in three layers and a
big furry coat with a nice little hat on
back in November we have gone through
Seasons man Seasons there were different
sports on back in November he just
doesn't play this way anymore he's
passed the ball for two straight games I
think this is the game where he says let
me do it myself he's got his pieces
around him I get it there's the Duncan
Robinsons there's the I was gonna say
Kayla Martin by a plan uh he's gotten
his guys around him I don't think they
get it done if they're relying on them I
know they have been relying on them but
I think Jimmy Butler's got to say let me
take things into my own hands Bam's been
doing it so I think Jimmy does it
tonight uh under six and a half assists
for Jimmy Butler
whoa my man Ryan's throwing a little
shade at Jimmy nice it's all good we
know you like the fade the superstars uh
he's a scorer man I just hit me Buckets
hey me Buckets yeah he's a he's a
playmaker I would I would classify Jimmy
Butler as a playmaker he can score he
could pass can I go grab rebounds he can
defend he's calling him a playmaker but
I'm rocking with you Ryan I'm sending
good vibes your way I hope that under
cases for you in the uh you know the
streak continues you can go 3-0 and in
the finals but uh MB MB we got the
rabbit on base we got Ryan on base we
need you to get himself we need you to
get him over so uh let's give him give a
show best bet
for today just a little just a little
ground ball to the second baseman gets
the runner over
um I think this is a big night for the
Nuggets I do think that they will win
the series but I don't think it's Gonna
Come Easy in game three so I'm going
with the Nuggets to trail by at least 10
points but then win the game I think
Miami has been starving for this moment
since they played in all those
championships back LeBron and Bosch and
Wade
the only time Miami really shows up is
when it really matters and I think that
they're going to be there in full force
tonight so I think the heat get out to a
really nice lead early
but I also think that the Nuggets will
make their run and end up winning this
game if you notice and I mentioned it a
little earlier in game two they were up
15 or something real late Jamal Murray
starts hitting threes and they cut the
lead down real fast this team this
nuggets team can turn it on like that
they kind of remind me in a weird way
Greg no like third quarter they do they
do
they just have this they just have this
switch they can just like get into their
offense and start making shots so my
play at plus 500 that's awesome value
when you're talking about a road a road
favorite plus 500 nuggets to trail by 10
and win the game
there it is my boy MBA I
is bro this is
the time uh Trail by 10 and then come
back in to win the game I like it man I
I can see this happen in Miami at home
getting out to an early lead and the
Nuggets coming back to establish
themselves into this NBA Finals uh
because this is a very important game
very very important game and now Michael
Bolin has moved the runner over so it's
time for me to bring him on it
two options here I'm giving you guys two
options you guys gave one pound I can
give you all two different bets all
right here we go I'm looking at rebound
totals rebound totals my man Jimmy
Butler
his rebound total sitting at six and a
half uh
I think he's gonna go over I think he's
gonna go over if you go look at his
rebounding numbers in the playoffs my
guy especially as of late he's been
going over this number he's been going
over the number so
you guys know what I said at home
defense you know usually with defense
comes rebounds so we're going to rock
with my guy Jimmy Butler to go over uh
six and a half rebounds I actually put
that on BR betting two I put that on the
story you guys helped me pick that one I
also had it marinated in my back pocket
so we're rocking with over six and a
half with Jimmy Butler and then on the
other side and B I got this from you you
like to play Both Sides sometimes with
the first one yeah yeah so on the other
side on the other side if you guys go
look at Michael Porter Jr rebounding
numbers over the last five six games my
man's been he's been rebounding the
basketball I think Mike Michael Malone
has been in uh has been talking to him
and telling him yo we need you to
rebound he's been putting a very
significant amount of uh effort into
rebounding uh in this playoffs he's
sitting in that seven and a half
rebounds
you guys help me on the story I also had
this one in my back pocket defense guys
defense defense I think he's gonna go
over that seven and a half rebounds so
there it is those two plays Jimmy Butler
over six and a half rebounds Michael
Porter Jr over seven half rebounds that
is what we are rocking with
um Greg let me just tell you that your
delivery on that mpj play is absolute
gold my man has been eating glass all
serious long bro Edie he has been going
crazy on the boards I think that's a lot
bro I think you got yourself one on that
that's that's all we could do is just
provide the schools that's it that's all
we can do is provide the Scoops uh all
right but you know we locked in the
parlay Ryan if you could pull up the do
we still have the parlay put up we could
pull up the parlay so the people can see
there it is there it is everybody
screenshot take a look at this the right
side of your screen you guys see it I'll
go over it right now right we got under
213 and a half total points we're also
rocking with Bruce Brown Jr under 10 and
a half points bam out of Bio under four
and a half assists and Aaron Gordon
under 16 and a half points that is an
alternate
that's an alternate right there that's
alternate points
um but we are calling this the player
haters parlay that's because we rocking
with all under so MB MB when we hit this
one what we gonna be doing man
uh you know what we gotta do we gotta
put our jackets on we got to put our
glasses on we got to put our hats on get
a nice little get a big cup to put our
drink in and we just said man
you ain't know what time it is we'll be
back here Friday sipping on our favorite
drinks with the new money that we made
that's what I want to do come on man
that's I see you Friday that's what we
gonna be to see you Friday we gonna be
right back here make sure you guys tune
in
um my name is Greg ivory for Ryan
producer Ryan uh oh other way for
producer Ryan and my man MB we are out
of here man
peace go win some money
[Music]
thank you
come on
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign